im hamburger hafen wo wir gerade darüber
sprechen findet übrigens gerade eine
kleine hsh feierstunde statt
albrecht humboldt ist der pressesprecher
albrecht
was haben sie denn da noch zu feiern
herr welke das ist ja jetzt genau zehn
jahre her dass der steuerzahler und
banken das erste mal den arsch gerettet
hat in der großen krise 2008 mit über 70
milliarden euro die jetzt einfacher weg
sind futsch im gully oder an einem
besseren ort
und da ist mir und den kollegen hier vom
bankenverband plötzlich aufgefallen
wir haben uns ja noch nie bedankt und
deshalb sagen wir heute danke
ja
gut dann würde ich sagen ist frische
draußen wir gehen wieder rein herberge
moment wie danke uns bürger hat auch nie
einer gefragt ob wir das zahlen wollen
das ist doch egal die geste zählt ich
meine das ist ja auch nicht
selbstverständlich jeder spende gerne
für robbenbabys oder einbeinige kinder
aber für typen wie wir ihn hier von der
commerzbank da braucht es schon ein herz
aus gold
ich würde ihn nicht mal zu einer
currywurst einladen gemacht die hsh hat
noch im letzten august vor ein paar
monaten einem hamburger reeder 650
millionen schulden erlassen
und jetzt müssen wir für eure kredite
geradestehen verstehe die frage nicht
das war ein rede der hatte schiff haben
sich gefällig glaube nicht jetzt müssen
wir für eure kredite geradestehen
wir haben uns doch gerade bedankt ja
irgendwann ist auch mal gut wir haben
sogar extra einen tv spot produziert
es ist immer da wenn politik versorgt
wenn banken unschuldig in not geraten
wenn es mal teurer sind
bruderländer dauert
steuerzahlergeld eine quelle die nie
versiegt du zahlst du und du auch wir
alle zahlen also außer google amazon
apple und ikea
[Applaus]
wie gesagt danke gut natürlich da kann
man jetzt noch ewig rumheulen weil das
ganze geld woanders fehlt in kitas oder
in der pflege aber das grundprinzip hat
sich doch bewährt wir die gewinne ihr
die risiken jeder nach seinen
fähigkeiten unverschämtheit das war
jetzt wirklich das letzte mal dass ihr
euch gerettet haben
[Gelächter]
herr welke demnächst gibt es eine
europäische einlagensicherung dann
haftet ihr auch für die faulen kredite
von griechischen und spanischen beinlich
heizung also ihr werdet euch noch in die
zeit zurück sehen als ihr nur für uns
bringen musste
so jetzt aber kommt der showteil sie
wissen ja als die hsh bank damals
gegründet wurde gab es eine fette party
stargast war bon jovi hammer so und
jetzt wollen wir natürlich auch feiern
dass die hsh nordbank als erste
landesbank privatisiert wird kommt
wieder bon jovi
diesmal mussten wir den schotter selber
bezahlen
meine damen und herren hier ist jürgen
milski
[Applaus]
hallbergmoos und jugendlichen